walker bueller overall has had an
outstanding year in the cy young race
when you think about walker bueller and
the slow ramp up from the beginning of
the year every month his era has come
down to aussie albies walks to the
plates which hit her batting left-handed
and he will get things going against
walker bueller
weak fly ball to left for aj pollock
and albie's is the first down of the
night jorge soleil came over at the
trade deadline from kansas city he hits
a big bouncer to turner at third
up and two down here in the first
from one dangerous hitter to another and
freddie freeman he smacks one on the
ground ashore there's seeger and there's
a one two three first on nine pitches
for walker bueller it's 37 year old
charlie morton who got off to a bumpy
start in the area above five after eight
starts but the era is around three since
mid-may
trey turner off the end of his back it's
a mile high pop-up and former dodger
jack peterson makes the play
and trey turner one for five now in the
series their number two hitter is max
muncie he's hit 29 home runs and a
feeble swing there 97 right down sunset
boulevard and muncie couldn't pull the
trigger two outs now mookie bets the
batter round ball weekly out to third
charging is riley he's got it he's been
so sure handed lately and he passes the
test here that's a one two three bottom
of the first inning in this pitcher's
duel out to a good start who set him
down in order on nine pitches in the
first inning now faces a guy having a
breakout season fifth in the league and
average fifth in the league in homers
well that pitch was a yard off of the
plate but he still goes around
and butter has his first strikeout one
down for the braves in the second comes
travis darno gets it down the right
field line toward the corner and date
mook he bets on the track he's near the
wall he reaches up and takes a home run
away
that was going over the short wall right
near the right field foul pole and
mookie betts got there reached up made
the catch and robs travis darnold
absolute highway robbery in right field
on the part of mookie betts turner
coasts into second with a lead off
double charlie martin who's been very
good overall this year has been less
good the more traffic there's been it
brings corey seeger to the plate got him
swinging strike three
that time it was the curveball that
solved corey seeger one down here in the
bottom of the second inning and the
second strikeout for charlie morton one
on one gun for will smith he came back
from three and oh to strike him out
looking third strikeout for morton two
down turner with the lead off double
still at second base aj pollock he
bought seventh in dave roberts order and
that's strike three
after a leadoff double charlie morton
strikes out the next three dodger
hitters he is very sharp score this game
into the top of the third it'll be the
blonde bomber leading things off for the
brave i like it chuck peterson has dyed
his hair blonde i fly ball toward right
bench is going to watch it go jack
peterson look like he got jammed and hit
it a country mile and the braves have
scored first there's some blonde
ambition one-nothing atlanta the way
these two guys are going that looms
large possibly one-on-one out for the
catcher travis darno now he pulls one to
left that ball is deep and that is going
to bounce and land on the warning track
riley around third he is going to score
without a throw darno messed up the
dodger defense and the braves add on
it's two to nothing charlie morton
carving through the dodgers like a
knife through warm butter six k's
and just one base runner over three
innings one guard on the fourth and
here's mookie bats that swings at the
pitch hits a high deep drive to left
field it is back it is going it is gone
a home run mookie bets
his second in as many games with the
dodgers on the board it's two to one
diana's still here and she still loves
it another mookie moment at dodger
stadium turner at second secret first up
to aj pollock then with two out it's on
the ground right to ozzie he's got it a
good throw and it wasn't freddy scooped
it up
that was nearly disastrous but charlie
morton gets a ground out when he needed
it most peterson leads from second base
and here's aussie albies and the pitch
swung and fouled off his knee and ozzie
down for the count and when ozzy albies
goes down you know that hurt
just above the left kneecap is it a lot
of discomfort well you just don't like
to see this
and they're going to pick up his legs
and carry him off folks
this is a bad scene
charlie morton makes his third trip
through the dodger order now max muncie
to lead off against charlie morton and
he just struck out muncie the breaking
ball gives him eight strikeouts and
morton all of a sudden back in a groove
he set down six in a row on the ground
freddie bobbles
adrianza backed him up and makes the
play
near disaster
but adrianza heads up
did his job so did charlie morton the
old 3-4-1 put out to send us to the
seventh with atlanta in front and the
dodgers have the tying run at third with
one out chris taylor who's coming up to
pinch hit the atlanta lead is in
jeopardy now
a sacrifice fly
from chris taylor ties the game at two
back into the bullpen they go lefty
lefty for max muncie tie game two on two
out in the seventh inning first pitch of
the sequence
swung on a high fly ball to right center
field solaire with the room shy the
warning track is there calls off jack
peterson and he's got out number three
and it took tyler just one pitch to get
the final out blake
we finished off last night's game
entering a 2-2 game in the eighth
top of the order instead of ozzy albee's
it's ira adrianza
moving away from it one down for atlanta
in the top of the eighth inning wow
real sharp
three consecutive sliders to get solaire
freddie freeman comes up check swing
[Applause]
in the braves order down one two three
and now it's a lead off walk to bets
here in the eighth inning that is hardly
the start you wanted here in the bottom
of the eighth corey seeger looking to be
the guy with a big hit swing on and
driven to the gap in right center field
that's going to get down and go to the
wall bets off to the races here comes
mookie bettson to score without a throw
the dodgers take the lead on a corey
seeger run scoring double it's three to
two the watts just have killed the
braves tonight they give the ball to
kenley janssen so dans be the final hope
chance in two outs on ten pitches big
right-handers one-two pitch
swung on and missed strike three dodgers
win
henley comes in to save it
3-2 final score and the dodgers are a
half game behind the giants in the
division standings they could take over
first place
as soon as tomorrow a 3-2 victory